eine million luxusvilla in flammen 1000
quadratmeter eine einzige feuerwand es
ist die villa des kopfhörer königs
sennheiser in isernhagen in
niedersachsen sie brennt komplett nieder
grund ist ein einziger kleiner akku
eines e bikes
meterhoch lodern die flammen aus dem
dach der sennheiser villa in isernhagen
bei hannover
um 6 uhr 12 schlägt die brandmeldeanlage
des luxus anwesens alarm die gluthitze
reißt die unternehmerfamilie aus dem
schlaf um 6 uhr 30 treffen die ersten
löschmannschaften am 1000 quadratmeter
großen bungalow komplex ein und bringen
erst einmal die geschockte dreiköpfige
familie in sicherheit
die betroffene familie stand bereits
draußen natürlich leicht bekleidet bei
sechs und zwölf die haben geschlafen
davor das verheerende feuer bahnt sich
eine schneise der verwüstung zur
rückseite des unternehmer anwesens
mittlerweile ist verstärkung am
einsatzort eingetroffen die löschtrupps
kämpfen mit aller kraft gegen den horror
brand ja also durch die rauchentwicklung
musste natürlich dass wir haben stets
vorgegangen werden und die
brandbekämpfung gestaltete sich im
ersten moment durch die starke
verrauchung schwierig der entstandene
schaden liegt bei 1,5 millionen euro
nach ersten ermittlungen der
kriminalpolizei hannover ist der brand
beim laden eines handelsüblichen e-bike
akkus ausgebrochen wie er in tausenden
deutschen haushalten vorhanden ist nach
lithium akkus das sind nun mal ist
elektronisches gerät und ein
elektronisches gerät defekt ist falsch
gelagert wird oder auch einer gewissen
witterung ausgesetzt wird dann ist es
anfällig und das kannst du nur feuer
kommen das warten auf das gebäude
übergreifen immer öfter werden die akkus
von der praktischen fortbewegung hilfe
zum feuerteufel wir gehen der gefahr auf
den grund
also ein einziger akku von einem e bike
das für dieses feuer gesorgt hat dort in
niedersachsen unglaubliche geschichte
wie kann das passieren
wir sprechen wir mit rainer weiskirchen
pressesprecher des schiff- und selbst
freiwilliger feuerwehrmann schönen guten
tag herr weißkirchen hallo kann das
überhaupt passieren dass sich das selbst
offenbar entzündet und an einen solchen
riesigen brand verursacht ein akku von
dem e bike das
problem fängt schon vor dem laden an
wenn ich zb eine falsches ladegerät
verwende es ein ladegerät das nicht
exakt zu dem akku passt dann kann es
sein dass die sicherungssysteme
entsprechend abschalten oder gar nicht
erst eingreifen wenn der akku zu
überladen droht es kann aber auch sein
dass der akku selber beschädigt ist was
gibt's dafür möglichkeiten
akkus liegen und der natur spanne
zwischen irgendwo null grad und 30 bis
40 grad das heißt also würde ich den
akku irgendwann mal zu heiß oder zu kalt
gelagert habe dann kann es passieren
dass dieser akku einen schaden genommen
hat es kann auch sein dass der akku mal
runter gefallen ist auch so eine
mechanische beeinflussung des akkus kann
dazu führen dass der separator dass die
schmale schicht zwischen plus und minus
diese akkus beschädigt wird und dann
kommt es zu einer blitzschnellen
entladung wir haben sehr hohe
energiedichten in modernen akkus zu
einem panel entladung dass es dann eine
kleine explosion
das ganze werde aq gegen flammen auf
wird extrem heiß und ist in dem moment
auch nicht mehr zu löschen und kann
natürlich dann umliegende materialien
entsprechenden plan setzen was kann man
machen um so einen brand zu verhindern
wollen
also ganz wichtig ich sage das immer
wieder gebrauchsanleitung lesen dass
sicherheitsaspekte wirklich beachten
nächste punkt ist ich habe das geht
schon angeführt wirklich auch exakt die
ladegeräte verwenden die zu den akku
gehören und nicht aus bequemlichkeit und
weil es vielleicht passt andere
ladegeräte verwenden dann schalten die
sicherheitssysteme entsprechen nicht ein
der nächste punkt ist aber auch wenn ich
den akku laden dann sollte ich das
irgendwie im blick haben also nicht über
nacht wo ich vielleicht gar nicht
eingreifen kann und
vielleicht dauert laden wo kann die
materialien mit in der gegend rumliegen
daneben liegen während der raum
entsprechend gefüllt ist wo das ganze
weitere feuer fangen kann dank an mein
name in weiskirchen danke rainer
weiskirchen verzeihen sie danke für die
erklärung in diesem so spannenden fall
und so unglaublichen fall da fängt ein
einzelner akku von einem e bike feuer
und vernichtet eine million wähler
darüber wollen wir hier im studio weiter
sprechen mit unserem frank ochse der
reinkommt auf seinem e-bike und uns
einmal zeigt was ist da los lebten
diesen akkus ist sehr gut fand ist doch
ist doch gut wir haben doch schon mehr
angefragt doch schon freie wahl zeigt
uns wo ist das gefährliche dinge also
akku der akku von diesem ebike genau ich
habe ein e-bike der ersten generation
sagt man so die sind nicht so waren auch
günstiger natürlich aber läuft immer
noch und hier sieht man tatsächlich
diesen akku den lade ich zu hause und
achte auch darauf dass natürlich nichts
brennbares internet ist also tatsächlich
auch fliesenboden oder auf steinboden
aber ich habe natürlich nach diesem
vorfall jetzt mulmiges gefühl dann
abends wirklich dann hier auch das
ladegerät anzupacken der verein nehme
ich mir wenn man das jetzt im heißen
sommer lange draußen stehen lässt das
kann ja dann auch gefährlich werden ich
hatte auch also ein problem ich habe
mich gestern erstmal informiert war ja
durch panisch war es passiert halt nur
beim aufladen und man kann auch sagen es
ist halt wirklich sehr sehr gering als
ich werden ja sehr sehr viel becks bikes
auch verkauft zum glück ist das wirklich
im promillebereich jetzt müssen wir
einmal auch über das thema versicherung
sprechen das ist natürlich ein
extremfall aber ihre der still zu hause
dieser kopfhörer könig sennheiser sein
fahrrad und ein womöglich in den keller
oder in die garage
das ding explodiert der akku explodiert
und die ganze millionen villa ist weg
wer zahlt der radhersteller der akku
hersteller die versicherung die
haftpflichtversicherung oder niemand das
ist tatsächlich relativ kompliziert
grundsätzlich gibt es ein
produkthaftungsgesetz das heißt der
hersteller muss natürlich für sein
produkt haften nur der wirt noch nicht
eben gleich bezahlen also wenn man dann
briefen und schreibt uns doch hier meine
wilders abgebrannt wird ehrlich sagen
hier sind jetzt die 1,5 millionen
deswegen tatsächlich erst springt
natürlich zuerst die feuerversicherung
oder die wohngebäude versicherung ein
und natürlich das bike ist natürlich
auch versichert durch die
hausratsversicherung aber nur dann wenn
wirklich e bikes und fahrräder
inkludiert sind da muss man wirklich ins
kleingedruckte achten da gibt's auch
riesen unterschiede tatsächlich premium
tarif wo gar keine fahrräder mit
eingeschlossen sind und es gibt auch
andere versicherung da kann man zum
beispiel seinen rat habe neben mit
10.000 euro versichern die werden ja
immer teurer das hat jetzt so 800
gekostet aber die kosten ja zum teil
6000 oder oder wirklich mehr also da
muss man darauf achten ist dass in
meiner hausratsversicherung drin und
natürlich brisant ist es natürlich auch
wenn ich zum beispiel hier das bike
stehen lassen und hier fängt es
plötzlich feuer dann muss man
privathaftpflicht einspringen weil ich
natürlich so recht jemandem schaden
zugefügt habe also es ist total
kompliziert aber mir natürlich mit einer
privat haftpflicht und einer
hausratsversicherung inclusive e bikes
und fahrrädern ist man schon auf der
sicheren seite frage ob sie vielen
herzlichen dank
geschwindelt danke für deinen besuch
hier im studio babbel selbst aber wie
gesagt
angehört so schon genug dann gefragt